marc vernier bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation tôt ce
matin sur rtl france alors on le disait
dès demain les discothèques peuvent
rouvrir vous est ce que vous allez
ouvrir votre établissement
et bien non je fais pas rouvrir un
établissement
ce week-end c'est évidemment contrecoeur
et c'est un réel des champs mais on a à
l'heure actuelle une conjoncture en
niveau 2 au niveau de ce qui nous est
imposée pour travailler qui ne qui ne me
laisse pas serein pour pour ce week end
à ouverture donc
donc non ce sont les contraintes qui ne
vont pas le pass annie terre une jauge
un cahier de rappel c'est trop
contraignant pour vous c'est très
contraignant parce que si on fait la
petite frise chronologique dans durant
la nuit si vous voulez on va voir des
clients qui vont pouvoir commencer à
sortir aller manger les commencé à faire
la fête dans les différents
établissements qui font que la vie
sociale française est très simple et
vont avoir un maximum de restriction le
plus tard possible dans la nuit c'est à
dire chez nous donc c'est évidemment un
gros problème
un gros problème de dynamisme sur nos
établissements on va avoir pu faire ce
qu'on voulait durant toute une nuit et
puis en arrivant chez nous il faudra
présenter
voilà un pass sanitaire avec soin à
vaccin valider les deux injections tout
ce qu'un jour soit un thé spécialement
48 ou un test antigénique réaliser donc
je vous doutez bien que on va avoir de
gros soucis pour essayer de pour essayer
pour une reprise de de donner une image
sympathique de nos discothèques qui
seront tous fermés depuis 16 mois
on a des générations qui connaissent
même pas les discothèques nous y voilà
si on commence à leur faire découvrir sa
de la sorte c'est compliqué on va y
revenir sur l'avenir les discothèques
néanmois est ce qu'on aurait pu faire
autrement pour pour cette réouverture
selon vous on aurait pu regarder
professionnellement ce qu'on avait
autour de nos différentes activités qui
arrivait quand même à faire à faire sens
et puis on pouvait regarder aussi
quelques exemples à l'étranger aussi qui
est on va dire prenait le pari de
pouvoir le réouvrir la discothèque qui
sont centraux de deux brides oui
finalement avec l'arrivée du variant
delta on en parle beaucoup en ces
derniers jours et cette crainte d'une
quatrième vague est ce que c'est pas un
pari risqué du gouvernement de permettre
cette réouverture des discothèques
effectivement en terme de timing
vous voyez sur votre sur votre édition
variant rayon delta est en train de
sauce et toutes les toutes les cartes de
différentes reprise d'activité après
est-ce que d'apprécier ça c'est un autre
débat évidemment mais est ce que toute
notre vie va être cantonné 1 le variant
delta le variant autres etc
mais quand même voilà sur 16 mois
d'arrêt sur notre activité sur les
niches sociales qui est commence de plus
en plus tristes ou laon ce qu'on nous
annonce que peut-être l'été va se finir
au 20 juillet voyez ce que je veux dire
une classe où là on a un débat de fond
et c'est de savoir ce qu'on veut faire
de nos vies c'est ce qu'on vous a
annoncé cesser ces dernières heures
c'est ça que les discothèques pourrait
fermer le 20 juillet c'est ce que vous
nous dites non non non on n'a pas eu
d'accord on a pas d'annoncé pas
d'annoncé de la sorte mais je salue sur
votre reportage discothèque de barcelone
ouvert depuis quinze jours qu'elles se
font déjà refermé le schéma le schéma
étrangers souvent et devient entame en
comparaison des fois aussi entre
différents gouvernements un autre schéma
donc
depuis 16 mois quand il ne se passait
quelque chose on va dire dans tel ou tel
pays s'était souvent c'était souvent par
mimétisme réalisé dans le nôtre donc il
ya une crainte wa évidemment donc c'est
ouais vous pariez de l'avenir de votre
profession aujourd'hui avec la crise
sanitaire est ce qu on a une idée du
nombre de discothèques qui ont fermé
définitivement leurs portes sur le
territoire alors il ya plus de 300
discothèque qui vont fermer
définitivement leurs portes sur le
territoire évidemment c'est évidemment
très très très très compliqué à se
projeter pour la profession encore on
avait déjà un gros pourcentage qui a
disparu et puis c'est surtout puis je
vous le disais tout à l'heure au niveau
du paysage social ou disparaît gentiment
mais sûrement donc on arrive déjà pour
certaines générations à faire vivre sa
vie sans les discothèques donc bah
comment on commence projeté est ce que
vous craignez finalement une disparition
des clubs de nuit à l'avenir ou le
disiez un oeil la nouvelle jeunesse va
peut-être pas forcément connaître un ce
qu'est une piste de danse ballet déjà
deux générations de des tout jeunes
majeurs qui la connaissent pas donc
ouais effectivement c'est au problème se
projeter se projeter et vente fin et en
utiliser le pire c'est évidemment c'est
évidemment compliqué pour nous mais il
faut y croire mais il ya en tout cas on
n'espère pas mais si cette part de
risque peut-être présente il faut pas
lui laisser la place et il faut surtout
pouvoir retravailler
dès qu'on peut comme il le faut et car
voilà pourraient avoir certains doutes
sur la disparition
nos établissements et notre métier si si
on vient quelque chose d' observer
normatif et de deux plongeons pour pour
la propre là les générations
on va dire les plus jeunes même les plus
anciens qui ont connu le monde de la
nuit avec avec toutes ces toutes ces
joies et tous ceux tous plaisir qui est
apportée à nos clientèles en quelques
mots il nous reste quelques secondes
l'état continue à vous aider est ce que
c est d sont suffisantes
alors chacun à son business plan propre
à son entreprise et on espère en tout
cas que les aides sous sont suffisantes
pour tous les tous les collègues de la
profession et elles vont courir
normalement jusqu'à août
évidemment on est toujours avant d'être
toujours pendu à la lecture d'un décret
sortant en cours
évidemment prorogé au passé c est donc
pour le moment
pour le moment voilà on devrait être
encore tranquille sur les semaines à
venir
merci beaucoup marc vernier d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
ce matin sur rtl france et on espère un
dès qu'on le pourra venir danser dans
votre boîte de nuit la première ça à
pontarlier et je le rappelle un exalté
du collectif s'est acharné en détresse